the Mazda 3 is now one of the world's
most popular compact Connor's the
Japanese car maker has sold more than
three and a half million worldwide and
is looking to attract more buyers in
Europe - and compete with the VW Golf
that enormous the new mazda3 is very
important for us as Yocum moon singer
from Asda for the past ten years ever
since the first generation was launched
it's been our top selling model
worldwide in all major markets and peer
in Germany two compact cars always sell
best let's take a look at the bodywork
first the Mazda 3 is the third model to
follow Mazdas new koto design philosophy
the sleek lines are designed to be
reminiscent of a cheetah ready to pounce
on its prey suggesting both strength and
speed
the effect is designed to work from the
front and the back the result is a
successful blend of elegance and sporty
dynamism
like the cx-5 and the mazda6
the new mazda3 also features the new
SKYACTIV technology dolphin says
SKYACTIV means highly efficient gasoline
and diesel engines it also involves a
new type of transmission and a
lightweight but rigid chassis he says it
features new technology and reusing
energy collected during deceleration for
example it couples efficiency with
driving pleasure as this car
demonstrates well the 110 kilowatt two
point two liter diesel engine we tested
for the maximum torque of 380 newton
meters has plenty of get-up-and-go even
at low revs it goes from 0 to 100 km/h
in 8 seconds and can reach a maximum
speed of 210 kilometers an hour the
model we tested sells in Germany for
just under 28,000 euros
Psychonauts our test driver Montes
curette says the 2.2 litre diesel engine
really shifts what's nice is it's got a
lot of pickup even at low revs he says
and you can really rev the engine if you
want obviously that guzzles more fuel
Mazda rates consumption at four litres
per hundred kilometers but in our tested
use just under six that's a bit
disappointing bozek's on dozens it is I
think it's an important if you like but
the new Mazda 3 is certainly sporting a
new wheel axle design makes the car both
safer and more agile the steering is
very tight giving the driver a greater
sense of control even when speeding
round bends handling is very good he
says and obviously in nearly all
respects it's better than its
predecessor the steering is more direct
you feel safer and better position on
the road it's really fun to drive that's
not a fish pond so fun the interior has
a high quality feel about it it's a
study and color contrast
the materials look pretty high-quality
at first glance he says but the
dashboard feels a bit rubbery here on
the door it's much more pleasant maybe
they could have struck a compromise here
the dashboard is obviously much softer
than the door a compromise between the
two materials would have been perfect
one plus is that everything can be
operated easily from the steering wheel
the interior feels uncluttered and tidy
an additional active driving display
puts important information directly into
the driver's field of vision
this combination instrument gives the
whole thing another sporty touch when I
find a bit of a shame is that the
speedometer is so low down in the corner
you have to pop up the active driving
display if you want to follow your speed
easily now it's time for a look in the
trunk a hatchback model offers 364
litres of space fine for a small amount
of luggage but the VW Golf is more
generous with 380 litres the Mazda 3 has
had more of a niche market in Germany
for a long time now but matus thinks
this new model can make it out of the
nation it's an all-round car with a
great design that's always a matter of
taste and it drives well on this montes
thinks it's good export so it's
definitely a car with potential prices
for the new Mazda 3 start at 17,000
euros in Germany that's 200 euros less
than the VW Golf
you